[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily rape allegations
against an international soccer star
could cristiano ronaldo go to court over
hush money payments
plus a grand jury wishes to speak
publicly in the killing of rihanna
taylor
our experts react to claims by
kentucky's attorney general
it was like she was an afterthought and
it angers me because it keeps
happening also one of the minnesota cops
accused of murdering george floyd is out
of jail
and is it graffiti or urban art a legal
victory for those who spray paint
lawn crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin let's go to
dramatic video right off the top now of
a man accused of kidnapping a
nine-year-old girl in providence rhode
island
police they're releasing this
surveillance video they say shows the
girl being abducted from her bus stop
monday afternoon
officers say the driver of a silver
nissan suv grabbed her off the street
and pulled her into the back seat before
driving away
the girl was dropped off about an hour
later at a nearby
location the suspect luis martinez
romero is facing charges of kidnapping a
minor
and second degree sexual assault he's
being held without bail
let's go to st louis missouri now where
a grand jury has indicted the couple
caught on camera displaying guns and
shouting to protesters outside their
gated mansion this summer
law on crime daily's terry austin is
here with that update terry
an attorney for mark and patricia
paklowski says the couple now stands
accused of the unlawful use of a weapon
and tampering with
evidence but the couple's attorney says
prosecutors tampered with evidence by
assembling a pistol
seized as evidence in a way that could
be fired
he says that is prosecutorial misconduct
the couple claims self-defense after
they brandished their weapons
as protesters entered their gated st
louis community
this past june former federal prosecutor
gene rossi
helps us break down the grand jury's
indictment
okay for the first charge of brandishing
the couple has a self-defense argument
there were allegedly protesters outside
that were threatening them
yelling at them this is what they may
say and they were fearful
the gate was pushed allegedly so they
held those guns
to defend themselves and their property
you can defend yourself
your property's another matter but but
they may have a self-defense case but
the tampering issue that one is going to
hurt them at trial
because jurors understand self-defense
they don't like tampering and what
tampering shows
is consciousness of guilt and it's a
relatively easy charge to prove
the attorney for the family of a man
killed by police in texas is calling for
video of the incident to be released
attorney lee merritt says jonathan price
was trying to help a woman in a domestic
violence situation at a convenience
store
according to a newly released probable
cause statement price was trying to
shake hands with wolf city police
officer sean lucas
lucas says he thought price was
intoxicated and tried to detain him body
camera video reportedly shows price
walking away as
lucas deployed his taser price
apparently then walked towards lucas and
appears
to grab the taser when the officer shot
price
the texas rangers are investigating the
case and say the officer's actions were
not
reasonable lucas was indicted on murder
charges
the officer's attorney told local
reporters after mr price refused
repeated instructions and physically
resisted
officer lucas deployed his taser and
continued to give mr price instructions
mr price resisted the effects of the
taser and attempted to take it away from
officer lucas
officer lucas only discharged his weapon
in accordance with texas law when he was
confronted with an aggressive assailant
who was attempting to take
his taser that's from attorney robert
rogers jump in for some analysis now
brian the details of this case are still
coming up is this reasonable or not for
the officer to have acted this way
let's put it this way when the police
department comes out with an indictment
this quickly and they affirmatively say
that based on their views
this is not reasonable it doesn't look
good for the defense for the defense
here that being the officer
and to be honest i'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired because we're
always hearing
that there's some some reason that
officers can respond to not listening to
commands with deadly force and that's
not what the law says
sir terry when you look at this from the
perspective of reasonableness or
non-reasonableness because that's some
of the standard here we have to look at
this objectively
does it make sense that the officer
would pull his gun and then
fire given that according to the video
apparently at least as it's relayed in
the
charging documents here that the person
who was shot who became a victim was
trying to take the taser because we all
know what the officers say they try to
say well if he gets the taser
and uses it against me then he can take
the gun and we hear this story roll out
in a number of cases
well that's exactly right we've heard it
roll out in too many cases the fact that
the
person is trying to take the taser and
the fact that the officer
responds with deadly force and frankly i
don't think any of this is going to
change we see
some changes in the law but we don't see
any change as far as the accountability
of the actual police officer is
concerned so we need to see
them charged indicted convicted and
jailed
so brian again if we go back to this you
know is it reasonable at all for the
officer to say
uh i feared for my life because this guy
was trying to take my taser
so when it comes to self-defense
reasonableness is is a two-part test of
objectiveness
and and also subjective subjectively
yeah i'm sure this officer was fearful
but objectively we're gonna have to wait
to see the video to really answer that
question
exactly i'm waiting for the video to
come out here again that's why we've got
the family saying we need to see
the interaction because the story may
change depending on how
long or how short this interaction
occurred
the ex-minneapolis police officer
charged with murdering george floyd is
out of jail on a one million dollar bond
derrick chauvin was released on a
conditional bond from the hennepin
county sheriff's office
he's the last of four officers charged
in floyd's death
to actually post bond chauvin has been
in jail since may on charges
of murder and manslaughter video
captured at the scene shows chauvin
kneeling on floyd's neck for almost
eight minutes
the four former officers facing charges
are scheduled to face a jury
next march prosecutors are asking the
u.s supreme court to affirm the death
sentence for the boston marathon bomber
the first circuit court of appeals ruled
that zohar tsarnaev
would spend the rest of his life behind
bars but that his death sentence needed
to be thrown out
the circuit court decided that what it
called extensive and sensational
pre-trial publicity
was not properly dealt with during jury
selection or during motions for a change
of venue outside of boston
the appeals court said the local jury
was neither impartial
nor indifferent the government is hoping
to have tsarnaev's death sentence
reinstated without a new trial
three died and 260 were hurt in the 2013
bombing
and still ahead on law and crime daily
we'll tell you which charges were
dropped and which ones
weren't in a case against a lawmaker
charged with protesting the killing of
brianna taylor
and later on world famous soccer star
cristiano ronaldo is in legal trouble
in the united states over hundreds of
thousands of dollars in payments he made
to a rape accuser
we break down the controversy when law
on crime daily continues
[Music]
kentucky's attorney general is being
asked to respond to a lawsuit by a
member of the grand jury in the killing
of brianna taylor
the grand jury convened in secret last
month one
officer was indicted for wanton
endangerment for firing into taylor's
neighbor's apartment
no officers were indicted over taylor's
death now an unnamed member of that
grand jury has filed a motion to speak
freely about the case saying they want
to make sure the truth got out about the
proceedings
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
answered questions about the indictment
at a press conference recently
and defended his actions statements
that were made by officers
there the night or the morning of march
13th
show that they did knock and announce
the important point here is that
information was corroborated
by another witness who was in close
proximity
to apartment 4 who cooperated that
information
and said that there was a knocking and
announcing by the officers
our team walked them through every
homicide offense
and also presented all the information
that was available
to the grand jury and then the grand
jury was
ultimately the one that made the
decision about
indicting detective hankinson
for wanting endangerment long crime
daily's brian buckmeyer listened to 15
hours worth of those grand jury
proceedings that's what's been released
thus far
and found some discrepancies with
cameron's statement brian
yeah eric the prosecutors barely
mentioned brianna taylor's name during
their presentation
had i not known the story beforehand i
wouldn't have really known this case
even involved her
although the prosecutor's legal
arguments were not made public it's hard
to believe
attorney general daniel cameron's team
presented any other charges aside from
wanton endangerment
against former officer brett hankinson
criminal defense attorney eclin mercy
who's not involved with the case
tells me she was shocked at how the
proceedings played out
at the moment in which we have one
witness saying one thing another
another what 11 witnesses saying
something else
that's a jury question and that's
something that should have been
been presented to the to the grand jury
and so it should have been presented at
trial
and my issue is is that he came in
trying to be a defense attorney to the
police officers and we have a problem
that's the problem he stated that he
presented
all the homicide charges to have a grand
juror
so so moved so passionate that he did
not do what he said
he was doing to even hire an attorney
because he lied is a problem he should
stand down
he should recuse himself this was a
gross misuse of justice
at the end of the day if the officers
even if the officers were found not
guilty at trial
they needed their day in court briana
taylor needed her
day in court and she wasn't granted that
and that's the problem
in a related case now felony riot
charges have been dropped against a
kentucky state representative and 17
others who protested
the indictment that we were just talking
about lawmaker attica scott is best
known for her proposed legislation
called brianna's law
which would ban no knock warrants if
it's passed
she was taken into custody on september
24th as she joined a group of protesters
in downtown louisville
the protesters said they were on church
grounds
as of 9 pm that's when a curfew is due
to set in
scott is however still facing two
misdemeanor charges of failure to
disperse
and unlawful assembly so brian as for
this legislator's case this is just very
odd that
you try to pass a reform bill and then
suddenly the police move in
and arrest you and you face felonies and
misdemeanors the good news for her from
her
perspective is that the felony is gone
so it's just lesser counts now but it's
still
important it's still serious absolutely
and and for most
uh cities that have protests myself
being in brooklyn
typically how these cases get worked out
is once the limelight is gone the
prosecutor often gets rid of the cases
because especially for this type of
story brianna taylor
i don't see a jury of six if it's a
misdemeanor or more
convicting her of any crimes and terry
as to what eklund mercy our law and
crime analysts here who joins us
frequently said about
how this process played out uh i i have
to look at it through eclin's
perspective here and say hey look you
know
where was the rest of the case because
it sounds like
it just wasn't there well that's exactly
right and eclin makes
an excellent point the grand juror who
came out
made a motion got a lawyer because all
of this
evidence wasn't presented that is so
unusual it's unusual for us to hear
the record actually it's unusual for a
juror to come
out and say we weren't presented with
all of that and
this case is unusual because it's taken
so long
even to get to the grand jury and then
finally obviously the fact that the
charges against hankinson
don't even deal with brianna taylor so
this case is really
unusual brian i forget the exact quote
but there's something
along the lines of the greatest burden
that your soul can bear is an untold
story
sounds like that's what this grand juror
has and they want to get it out
exactly the way that uh attorney general
daniel cameron presented this
as i think even gene rossi said earlier
is that
this was not how a prosecutor speaks
about a case it's not how a prosecutor
presents a case
as and as i said as well if prosecutors
present cases like this
i'm out of a job because he was more
defense attorney than prosecutor wow
brian buckmeyer worried about his career
potentials here on law and crime dealer
but
daily but point well taken well later on
in our broadcast we're going to break
down a complicated rape accusation
against the world's second highest paid
athlete
and legal graffiti artists mark a legal
win against a building owner who they
say destroyed their legitimate art
the federal law that was on their side
when we return
on law and prime daily
a legal victory for legal graffiti
artists in the new york city area
the u.s supreme court has refused to
take a case filed by artists who
displayed
their work at the five-point site in
long island city
the high court's rejection leaves in
place a second circuit court of appeals
decision
which ruled the visual artists rights
act applied
and that aerosol artists had certain
rights in their work
even though they didn't own the building
it was attached to
the building's owner originally agreed
to turn what the second circuit referred
to as his
dilapidated warehouse buildings into an
exhibition space for artists
the artists actually rented space and
spray painted the building so brian
buckmeyer that's one of the keys to
understanding this case this was not
illegal graffiti this was a legitimate
contractual relationship
among an owner of a building or a
complex and artists
and that's why the art enjoyed legal
protection and didn't end up with the
artist becoming
your clients in criminal court exactly
and aaron it even goes beyond that i
mean i went to
queen's college in flushing new york
queens and if you took the 7 train
into the city you saw this magnificent
artwork that once was dilapidated
property that no one wanted to look at
we turned away we were on the train
and it was something so was so gorgeous
and so beautiful that the whole
community was really rallying behind
them
so terry the statute here gives artists
and it can be any artist we have to keep
that in mind
certain rights against the destruction
of their works but that's only if the
works have achieved recognize
stature brian just explained some of the
recognized stature here he
knows this project he knows the facility
he knows the building he knows the art
can you explain the law here a little
bit well the law is only going to
protect
that artwork if in fact to your point
there is some sort of agreement and in
addition
that the artwork and the artist have
some sort of stature in the community so
it can't just be
a mark on the wall it has to be
something that people
have looked at they have respected and
the artist
has to be honored in that regard so it's
certain
types of artwork not just any old
graffiti
it was interesting brian because the
decision talks about how the art was
changing at this facility
where there were some pieces that were
considered always
important and always to be there and
other parts of it were changing so
that plays into that legal argument
exactly it was an interesting aspect
as it applies to the law because for the
community and that statute part that i'm
really talking about on the end there
it grew it developed it was organic and
we all knew in queens what it was
especially people who went back between
new york and queens
uh manhattan and queens sorry uh i think
it very much fit the statue here and i'm
glad they got that legal win
it's certainly an interesting argument
let's check in now with lon crime chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
with what he's working on this week
brian
thanks aaron coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
with the consequential election just one
month away growing concerns that the
results
could be compromised we'll talk with the
former head of national security at the
department of justice
about his greatest fears their goal is
to turn
americans against americans that's this
week on brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
back to you erin and when we come back a
couple of cops in maine are on the other
side
of the law facing charges involving the
killing of porcupines
and it's causing quite enough roar we'll
explain when we return
[Music]
two police officers in maine are now off
a local force after a third officer is
said to have recorded them
beating wild porcupines to death with
their police batons and it all
apparently happened when they were
supposed to be out solving crimes
27 year old addison cox and 30 year old
michael rollerson
are accused of sharing videos of
themselves killing the animals on
internal police department
snapchat channels which were supposed to
be used to boost
employee morale they've both been fired
and
are both now charged with aggravated
animal cruelty and other counts
rollerson admitted he
pepper sprayed some porcupines similar
to ones you're going to see in just a
moment pictured at a zoo
and admitted he probably killed
somewhere around eight animals
cox admitted to killing about three
porcupines after ironically being
pictured
rescuing other animals on his
department's
facebook page the officer accused of
making these recordings
claims he didn't do it before news of
the charges broke but after kicking the
officers off the force the local police
chief
seemed agonized that he couldn't say
more maine's laws relating to employee
discipline do not allow those details to
be released
at the time i follow the law a
tremendous amount of power is given to
those who wear a badge and are
tasked with protecting their communities
it's a power that i do not take lightly
i'm asking you to trust that if there
were an allegation of police misconduct
i would take it very seriously
and any investigation would be conducted
appropriately always placing public
safety and community trust
at the forefront that statement was
dated last week since then the charges
were filed
and the reports are starting to become
public
international soccer star cristiano
ronaldo might be heading to trial over a
rape accusation that's more than a
decade old
ronaldo is accused of assaulting a woman
he met at a las vegas nightclub in 2009
police reopened the case in 2018 but
prosecutors later said they would not
pursue criminal charges due to a lack of
evidence
up for question now is whether the woman
who accused ronaldo
was mentally capable of entering into a
375 thousand dollar non-disclosure
agreement in 2010.
ronaldo lives in portugal and plays for
an italian soccer team
his lawyers say sex occurred but was
consensual
the accuser alleges battery coercion and
fraud
a federal judge in nevada will hear
arguments in november and could set
a trial date so brian we're talking
about one of the top
soccer players in the world here one of
the richest athletes in the world
how can we be assured that this case
gets a fair investigation
so it's ironic when we talk about
athletes in america because often times
there are such
hell to a higher standard but because i
think soccer's not that big of a country
you know aaron you and i are even
talking about christian ronaldo
and we were trying to compare notes uh i
don't think he's gonna get that level of
status that
aaron rodgers or someone else in this
country would this is a claim simply
about a contract though where she's
asking for 200 000
for a man who's worth 450 million
dollars i would assume he'd probably
settle before anything else
so terry it seems as though judges are
overriding these non-disclosure
agreement agreements more and more
these days do you think the civil case
has grounds to move forward
i do i mean i think that the
confidentiality agreement
it all depends on what is in there you
know she's claiming
that he shouldn't have allowed the
information to be published
he's claiming that he had nothing to do
with it that it was
all hacked so depending on what the
confidentiality agreement states
i think she has a very good chance of
winning that civil action and winning
to brian's point the amount of money
that she's asking for the two hundred
thousand dollars because
based on what he's making that's just a
drop in the pool
we've got a lot of dollar amounts flying
around here we've got non-disclosures
we've got
other accusations for settlements and
whatnot so it'll be interesting to see
exactly how that judge rules brian and
terry good to be with you here on law
and crime daily and thank you for
joining us we'll see you back here next
time to discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you